-Anyways, I usually write ou
my thank you notes earlier
but, if you guys wouldn't mind
can I write it out right now
Is that okay?
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys are the best.
James, can I get some
thank-you note writing
music, please!
-[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Got a cardboard cutout
of James. That's great.
-[ Stops playing ]
-Yeah. Oh, he's moving
his fingers, though.
[ Laughter ]
So you can tell that he's real
♪♪♪♪
Thank you, CDC lifting
the mask and social distancing
requirements
for vaccinated people,
for being the real
friends reunion.
[ Cheering and applause ]
See?
-Come on, that's a thinker
[ Scat singing
"I'll Be There for You" ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
It's like
when "The Brady Bunch"
had a sad moment, like --
[ Scat singing mellow jazz ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
"Friends" are reuniting.
[ Scat singing jazz
"I'll Be There for You" ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah!
-They're walking away.
-Yeah. Sad.
It's going to be sad.
-Yeah.
-You ever hear this part
of "Friends"?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rattling ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Now, back to the show.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you,
Starbucks' new
funnel cake frappuccino,
or as your arteries put it
"Wait, are you mad at me?
-Aw.
-What did I...?
-"What'd I do to you?"
-What did I do?"
-I guess you don't like
your feet.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you,
Amazon Fire TV stick,
for being a vape pen
that works in IT.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Totally cool.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, IKEA's new
lingonberry pulled pork
sandwich,
for sounding weird, until yo
remember you're ordering
Swedish barbecue
from a furniture store.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's the weird part.
-Not the lingonberry.
-No.
I was going to say
your sandwich choice is weird.
-No.
-You're ordering
a sandwich in a --
-Where?
-Yeah, in an IKEA,
so, yeah, that's weird.
-That's nuts.
-Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
Thank you,
people who wear tiny fedoras
for letting me play the game
Bald or Jewelry Salesman?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Jewelry salesman?
-Hey, now, you're an all-star.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, Dalmatians,
for looking like you're
really bad at paint ball.
[ Awws, laughter,
and applause ]
They just want
to play the game.
-They just want to play
a game, man, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, letter openers
for letting me shiv
my cable bill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Shh!
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, beer flights,
for being the classiest
way to say,
"I'd like five beers, please."
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you go, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes!